ces premiers bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors comment
les parents ont réagi face aux règles
énoncées par le gouvernement pour cette
rentrée
aimer écouter de manière très diverse
puisque nous avons vu le protocole
sanitaire que qui a été sortie d'été est
dite et la semaine dernière donc très
complet très dense et de toute façon il
y à une pluralité de réaction chez des
parents d'élèves
alors certes s en inquiète évidemment
comme vous l'avez titré tandis que
d'autres qu'ils ne sont pas moins ont
quand même décidé de mettre leurs
enfants à l'école si des conditions sont
réunies il faut savoir que nos
associations et nos parents d'élèves qui
sont autonomes
en fait ils zappent ici au cas par cas
des différentes situations auxquelles
ils sont confrontés
et dans ce cas prennent ou non la
décision donc de deux de faire entrer
leurs enfants alors selon vous les
laissez règles qui ont été émises en par
le ministère de l'éducation nationale
sont elles applicables dans les
établissements scolaires alors
premièrement ces règles évidemment je
veux dire que nous ce ne sont pas nous
par avance et socialistes de la question
de sécurité sanitaire donc a priori nous
faisons confiance
simplement nous apprécions s'ils règlent
au regard des de la configuration des
bâtiments dans lesquels évoluent nos
enfants donc certains parents ont été
rassurés d'autre part et en conscience
ils ont pris ou non la décision donc
de faire entrer leurs enfants il va sans
dire que nous fédération de parents nous
nous sommes vigilants là-dessus et nous
avons continué de dire que la confiance
n'exclut pas le contrôle
il va sans dire que si le moindre risque
le disons la moindre faille concernant
le dispositif d'accueil de nos enfants
donc s'il ya le moins de risques que
nous serons vigilants et nous saurons
faire porter la parole des parements
alors vous l'avez dit certains parents
ne souhaitent pas remettre leurs enfants
à l'école qu'en est il des professeur es
ce que vous avez des détails comment
est-ce qu'ils vont justement mettre en
place ces règles cela va changer un
petit peu le fonctionnement en classe
oui alors il faut dire que de toute
façon pour que mon enfant soit où que
l'ensemble des enfants soient
correctement accueilli au cours du mois
de mai quelle que soit la dette
eh bien il faut une conjonction il faut
que plusieurs acteurs soient mobilisés
il faut que non seulement les
enseignants mais également le personnage
sera tiff le personnel technique et
d'accueil
le personnel qui travaille sous la
logistique les élèves les parents soient
engagées soient impliqués et que en fait
tout ce petit monde là doit apprendre
lorsque la configuration des lieux de
permet donc tout ce petit monde là doit
apprendre à évoluer en fonction de
nouvelles règles il est évident qu'en
l'espace de quelques semaines
le problème que nous avons affrontée ne
sera pas résolue on se pose même la
question sur les mois à venir et
vraisemblablement nous aurons dans
l'année dans les deux ou trois ans qui
viennent
adopté un nouveau mode de comportement
donc le problème des complexes cela
concerne les enseignants mais également
tous les autres acteurs y compris les
parents d'élèves les collectivités sont
engagés bien entendu puisqu'elles sont
raison charge la gestion du bâti des
installations il va sans dire que
si si nous voulons que nos enfants
reprennent en fait tous les acteurs
doivent être engagés dans la même
direction
dernière question gérard paumier est ce
que pour vous et pour la fédération que
vous représentez cette date du 11 mai et
finalement prématuré pour la rentrée
scolaire
nous ne sommes jamais fait une fixation
sur la date en laine même les
symboliques
d'ailleurs il était déjà annoncé que la
rentrée envisagées serait très
progressive et effectivement on a vu que
ce national pourrait se faire que par
petits groupes
donc le 11 mai c'est une date symbolique
ne faisons pas une fixation là dessus
merci beaucoup gérard premier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de la fédération des
parents d'élèves de l'enseignement
public